it's no secret that here on battle
damage we've got it out for phones in
our quest to make sure phones never feel
safe continues it's thanks to your
request today we're going to be battle
testing four popular iPhone cases be
warned phones no case will save you from
our raft
first up is the lifeproof case which
says it's built to exceed US military
standards for dropping next we have the
lunatic extreme with impact trusses and
fancy Gorilla Glass shield the griffin
survivor + catalyst is waterproof and
ruggedized where it counts the edges and
corners last but certainly not least is
the OtterBox Defender which uses a
robust three layer protection and has a
swiveling belt clip
I'm going to try to throw this as hard
on the screen as I can since that's what
they're meant to be protecting and roll
action
front came off yeah phones on its face
it came out it does not look good screen
isn't turning on I mean it looks the cut
it does look then actually it buzzes
like it's on but the screen is mean
that's not usable survivor did not
survive oh well the case I'm sure will
snap back together befo little busted
open to split right in the front I'm
hearing no sounds no clicks nothing
it's testicle killing so many iPhones
there we go
mama truth phone still on Network that's
already beaten its competitors
incredibly hard to hit volume button
work up so it definitely bulged a little
bit right here but Cole usable worth the
75 bucks
yeah if you're going to slam your phone
to go
you smash it it's like Fu King Batman
made a move screen side up still on so
right away
it stopped the first two casing has come
apart seems like a little bit flimsy a
little bit cheap phone is fine it's in a
very similar shape as lunatic extreme
looks great
OtterBox moves on these two are taking
the safe our two survivors have made it
past the spike test but can they handle
a 50-pound safe let's find out
yeah awesome feeling about that ready
roll
thank you
Oh
that alone is vaporized Oh what's left
of either the phone or the case it is
bent in half hamburger style holy crap
so is that a pass or fail I think that's
a fail
I've never seen an iPhone fold in half
Wow here we go ready roll
the phone is still ah alright I'm going
in that is insane
I think it works so the cases glass is
broken but maybe the phone's trash is
still okay so we got the special tool
that it comes with
in fact the screen is still working
leads me to believe that it's pretty
much undamaged under there
it's definitely bent not so bad though
is the screen scratched at all I don't
think so
hardcase kept it rigid and then you can
see there's all these little empty
pockets those probably like compress
like a Twinkie and that basically
absorbs the confession and you can drop
safe on your phone we have a really
clear winner in this test
big time winner is the lunatic extreme
well turns out most of the time your
phone's not even safe in the case that's
why I always carry my phone in one of
these a special iPhone case of my own
design I call it the case today wow
that's pretty cool can you fit it in
your pocket easily oh jeez these must
have shrunk in the dryer right what do
you use to protect your phone or do you
let it go commando give us a shout out
in the comments and be sure to subscribe
to the wire channel so you don't miss
our slow it fits fit oh no I just broke
my pants that looks painful
medic
see you next week